56 books of the bible together
okay that's a long long response yeah
the old testament was settled by the
time of artaxerxes
it was settled the third and they called
22 but
we know 30 likes comes some are just
mingled together like samuel
kings and chronicles 39 books were set
by artaxerxes 400 bc
the new testament began to be
established in the days of paul
and peter because peter go to second
peter chapter 3.
ii peter chapter 3
verse 3 verse 16 peter is writing to the
church
i think the church of rome ii peter
chapter 3
let's read verse 16. do you have that
read with me what does it say
as also in all his epistles
speaking in them of these things in
which are some things come on
hard to be understood which they that
are unlearned and unstable
rest as they do also the other
scriptures unto their own
destruction he is referring to the
writings of paul
he's not about paul he mentions paul in
verse 15.
he says his writings are difficult to
get and some people
they're not spiritually mature they
misunderstand his writings in other
words
paul's writings were being used peter
was
referring to them now go to ii timothy
no first timothy 5 read verse 18.
first timothy 5 verse 18.
i think that's it yes first thing with
timothy 5 verse 18.
we 17 and 18 so we get some connection
first timothy 5
17 and 18. you have that
come on nice and loud read for me let
the elders that
rule well be counted worthy of double
honor keep reading
especially they who labor in word
and doctrine that's the interesting
passage for the elders to study
let the elders that rule well
be counted worthy of double honor
especially those who labor in
modern doctrine verse 80 now
for the scripture saith thou shalt not
muscle the orcs
that treadeth out the corn finish that
verse and the laborer
is worthy of his reward now where did
paul get
the laborer is worthy of his reward go
to luke chapter 10.
luke chapter 10.
read for me verse 7 luke 10 verse 7
christ is giving
instructions to his disciples if you
have my version read for me what does
that say
and in the same house remain eating and
drinking come on
as they give keep reading for the
laborer
is worthy of his hire paul is quoting
the words of christ which means
the words of christ were circulating as
having authority
so we have paul quoting christ we have
peter
referring to paul the new testament was
being formed
and the churches were the ones
determining
which represents inspired writing and
which does not
now about 150 about that
there was a heretic called marcion
marcion compiled a collection of books
which he called his bible
he left out almost the entire old
testament left out a lot of the new
kept much of the writings of paul i
think kept luke and that was his canon
when he did that the church panicked the
church realized
we have to settle this this this cannon
because this heritage he was a heretic
marcion didn't believe in the old
testament god he said he was too bloody
he's too bloody he can't be so he just
ditched firstly the whole old testament
much of the new and just kept a few
epistles then the church started to act
to assemble the books which were
authoritative and holy
and by the time of the damascene council
in 382
led by pope damasus the new testament
canon had been settled gorham psalm 12
psalm 12. so the books were written by
about 40 writers over 1500 years
and the church assembled the books as
authoritative under the guidance of the
spirit of god
now why do i say under the guidance of
the spirit of god do you have
psalm 12 is that what i said
read verse 7
no six and seven the words of the lord
are
pure words as silver try in a furnace of
the earth
purified seven times now pause now get
ready
now you read verse heaven thou shalt
preserve
go on yes
keep reading yes
god knows how to preserve his word
and he guided the church i'll tell you
another reason why these books are
reliable
if you read the writings of the early
fathers
you have the anteneeson and the
post-nascent fathers
anthony means before the after before
sorry the council of nicaea and post
means
after the council of nicea which meant
in 325 and the
the all these men of the church when
they quoted they quoted from the books
we have now
they did not quote from the apocrypha
the catholic bible has about seven or
eight books called the apocrypha
which is not in a christian bible those
books are not regarded as
inspired and they were not quoted by the
early church fathers
and so the church under the guidance of
god's holy spirit develop what is called
the canon
the canon means something that measures
and they decided these
are authoritative from god inspired from
god
and we have the 66. it's interesting to
know that
martin luther whom god used so
powerfully did not like the book of
james
he just thought it was a bunch of straw
he did not like you see god's message to
him was
the just shall live by faith james
stress works
as proof of faith and luther did not
fully understand james message
so he called it an epistle of straw and
he did not think it
it going to go so god can use you but
you're not perfect
you can have some shortcomings all right
next question